[Music]
first question what are the following
people have in common Malcolm X Enoch
Powell John Lennon Bertrand Russell and
Henry Kissinger what they will have in
common is that there were all men who in
their respective and very different ways
to find the 1960s but they were also
people who were debated with cajoled by
tariq Ali's our guest here today he's
had an amazing life his perspective is a
unique one particularly for those of us
who came of age in the post 9/11 era I
remember as a student hearing him on
anti Iraq war demonstration and what
struck me was his refreshing lack of
even-handedness on the issue and his
panache passionate sort of denunciation
of what the US and the UK were about to
embark on and which really you know
hasn't hasn't ended since then since
2003 really he's also I should say a
very fine novelist and if anyone who
hasn't read his books about Islamic
setting the Islamic world Islamic
history I advise you to do so because
they are terrific filmmaker as well and
also a screenwriter and just recently we
learned that there's an as yet as yet
unknown film script of the late via
snipe all's a house for mr. Biswas that
Tariq has so if anyone's here from
Netflix what are you doing but Tariq
let's just start with you early life you
were born in what was now you know what
was then colonial India British ruled
India and partition happened I think
when you were very young do you have any
memories of partition and did it affect
you in any you know how did it affect no
partition happened when I was just so
three-and-a-half and so my memories of
it are non-existent largely I think
because my family itself didn't face any
traumas we weren't refugees from one
part of India to the other I mean part
addition of the Indian subcontinent was
a horrific event nearly 2 million people
died in 1947 Hindus Muslims Sikhs
killing each other as the country was
divided but we lived in a part of India
which became part of Pakistan and my
family the bulk of it wasn't affected
older cousins recalled traveling from
their schools in Simla etc and cranes
alone and their parents not knowing
where they were but no one died
fortunately which can't be said for many
many other people rich and poor mainly
the poor who suffered well I think at
that time till 1946 apart from the
Congress the other parties were prepared
for some sort of compromise which was to
keep India United but to give maximum
autonomy to many of its regions and see
how it went for another four or five
years that plan was never put into
practice and this hurried rushed
partition led to many deaths and
killings I think it could have been
avoided but then you know when you say
that to people today they say we'll look
at the state of India how the minorities
are being treated we were probably right
to do it but that's you know sort of
being White's after the event
I mean maybe these things wouldn't have
happened had there been no partition but
the debate goes on your family were
politically active they had a radical
history to them and do you did you sort
of imbibe their ideas about you know
social justice from an early age well my
family you mean my parents they were
very radical the family as a whole was
deeply reactionary I I have to confess
very nice people but politically
completely on the other side
have remained ever since but I was lucky
in terms of my parents who were very
radical and yes they had a big influence
on me and not just them but the whole
social milieu of painters and artists
and poets and trade union leaders and
peasant leaders going through our house
that had a big impact on one and you
know they were just more interesting
people than the family at large as you
relate in your memoir street-fighting
years you you go to you go to Oxford and
is that really when you start reading
the text well I read some of the texts
you know the books by Marx and Lenin etc
in Pakistan they were available though
some of the more clandestine literature
Byron Oxford I got the libraries and
availability of books which were never
available in Pakistan especially it has
to be said critiques of religion and so
for me Oxford was very liberating on
that level if not academically I mean
you know when you when I think back on
the philosophy we were taught at it etc
it was very limited to to sort of
linguistic in English philosophy there
were no critiques of that available
Spinoza wasn't tall Nietzsche was bored
etc etc so but on the other hand that
the milieu and the other people were met
and talked and related to was very
important here so just I'm thinking a
bit further to the who would you say
well you know when you were an Oxford
that an early time who was the most
influential thinker the UN who was the
who was the person who really thought
wow this is reformulating the way that
I'm well I I guess that the books which
had a huge impact on me the first was
Isaac torches amazing trilogy a
biography of Trotsky it was not a think
I dread greatly in pakistan's not
available and the Deutsche trilogy had a
very big impact on me apart from its
politics it's pure
exquisitely written and it's interesting
it make one think that of the to polish
exiled to Britain Joseph Conrad early on
and I signature later on their ability
to grasp and even transform the English
language and the way they wrote was
important and I think it was the
combination of reading Isaac Deutsche
which then drove me to read Trotsky's
history of the Russian Revolution and
develop a left critique of Stalinism own
what passed for socialism or communism
in those days that was extremely
important I think intellectually for my
formation at the same time of course the
Vietnam War was starting knees started
to go on demonstrations and how did the
sort of ideas that you read in Trotsky
or inform your sort of activism annual
demonstrations it was it was it you
instinctively knew well you know Vietnam
war is just just wrong or is always it a
sort of did you develop a critique that
was more boats but not at the same time
during I mean I was very engaged in
activism in Pakistan even under the
military dictatorship where you know you
went on a demonstration and you didn't
know whether how many people are going
to be killed on it I mean there's one
demonstration we were on and we charged
our motor scooter guards went through
the police lines and they opened fire in
to students standing at about that
distance which are dead so the next day
there are a hundred thousand students
turned up it was living on the edge
really in many many ways but we were
very active on Vietnam even as teenagers
following the war it's the 50s war waged
by the French and interestingly in the
post-colonial world the Vietnam War had
a huge impact a distant relative of mine
a film director not at all political his
son was born on the same day as the
biggest defeat the French suffered Dien
Bien Phu in 1950 he just named his son
Ho Chi Minh I mean the
boy was teased out of his life at school
he just named him Ho Chi Minh and when
we said why did you do that he said you
know what a great victory and so it's
not just people who were politicized but
lots of ordinary people very inspired by
that and so from that to Britain I just
moved that type of activism with me you
know we used to rq-- explain why the war
was wrong etcetera etcetera
Harold Wilson was the prime minister at
a time like I think that your first book
was was thoughts of had thoughts of
Chairman Harold is that right that was a
book suggested by the then editor of
private eye richard engrams who said
that you know so much about what he used
to think before he came to power that
why don't you compile his sayings all
the progressive things he said and we
put it out as the thoughts of chairman
Harold with drawings by Ralph Steadman
very vicious cartoons yeah that that was
the first little book I wrote for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you